en el vídeo pasado estuvimos trabajando
con nuestra matriz y con la forma
escalonada de esta matriz al que le
habíamos llamado r para encontrar una
base del espacio columna de a y la forma
de encontrar esta base del espacio
columna de amd era utilizando el
siguiente método tomábamos la matriz amp
y la poníamos en su forma escalonada ya
que en su forma escalonada nos fijábamos
en aquellos sectores columna que fueran
pivote es decir un vector columna que
fuera pívot en era que el vector columna
que solamente tuviera un uno en uno de
sus componentes y en todas las demás
componentes cero y entonces decíamos que
los vectores columnas asociados a estos
vectores pivote de la matriz am eran los
que formaban la base del espacio columna
de amd y por lo tanto si nosotros nos
fijamos en la dimensión del espacio
columna de an en este caso nos daríamos
cuenta que es 3 porque tenemos tres
elementos a 1 a 2 y a 4 ya habíamos
dicho que la dimensión del espacio
columna de amd le llamábamos con un
nombre importante con el nombre del
rango el rango de una matriz ahora lo
que no vimos en el vídeo pasado 19
y quiero trabajar en este vídeo es
entender por qué los vectores pivote de
la forma escalonada de la matriz
están completamente relacionados con los
vectores columna de la matriz a pero
antes de eso quiero que recuerdes que si
nosotros nos fijamos en la forma
escalonada de la matriz son los vectores
pivote r1 r2 y r4 forman un conjunto de
vectores linealmente independiente estos
tres vectores son linealmente
independientes y bueno esto lo habíamos
visto es justo por construcción porque
si tú eres una columna pivote entonces
vas a tener un 1 en una cierta entrada y
las demás columnas pivote van a tener
ceros en esa respectiva fila por lo
tanto no va a existir forma de tomar los
otros vectores columna de tal manera que
yo pueda obtener un 1 en esa entrada y
de igual manera para las otras columnas
pivote porque las otras columnas pivote
van a estar formadas por un 1 en una de
sus entradas y 0 en sus demás entradas y
bueno cuando hablo de linealmente
independiente me refiero a un conjunto
de vectores linealmente independiente y
no sólo eso cualquier conjunto de
columnas pivote de cualquier forma
de la matriz a es linealmente
independiente y esto tiene toda la
lógica del mundo y se basan más o menos
en lo mismo de lo que acabo de decir
porque cuando nosotros tenemos una forma
escalonada de la matriz a sea cual sea
entonces las columna pivote tienen un 1
en el de sus entradas y en todas las
demás entradas tienen 0 pero bueno esto
lo voy a usar porque quiero que te des
cuenta de algo si este conjunto de
vectores columna pivote son linealmente
independientes entonces van a cumplir la
siguiente ecuación que ese 1 por r 1 c 1
por ere 1 más c 2 por r 2 más de 2 por r
2 + c3 c4 por r 4 esto tiene que ser
igual a 0 si sólo siguen sea 1 c 2 y c 4
son 0 recuerda que esto es justo la
definición de que sean linealmente
independientes esto va a pasar solamente
si se 1 c 2 c 4 son igual a 0 entonces
déjame ponerlo aquí si yo tengo esta
forma escalonada de la matriz y la
multiplicó por el vector
c2 c3 y ds3 voy a plan 0 c 1 c 2004 y 0
es decir voy a reemplazar c3 y c5 por 0
y bueno esto lo puedo hacer porque este
es un caso particular de encontrar un
espacio nulo de la forma escalonada de
la matriz a y por lo tanto esto lo hago
igual al vector 0 el vector 0 con cuatro
componentes entonces date cuenta que
esto no quedaría 1 x c 1 + 0 x c 2 + 0 x
menos uno o lo podemos ver mejor de la
siguiente manera en lugar de hacer toda
la multiplicación de esta matriz por
este vector voy a recordar una propiedad
que ya habíamos visto que propiedad a
pues que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que perder ser 1 por mi vector columna 1
como c 1 x ni vector columna 1 pero mi
vector con una 1 0 1 entonces déjame
ponerlo aquí me quedaría c 1 por el
vector columna 1 pero es r 1 más de 2
por ere 2
pero por r3 pero como estoy
multiplicando por 0 pues esto se va
entonces lo que daría más 04 por ere 4
más ere 5 por 0 pero pues al multiplicar
por 0 esto se va y esto es igual a 0 y
date cuenta de que aquí hay algo muy
importante c 1 c 2 y c 4 tienen que ser
0 además de que habíamos dicho el que es
un conjunto linealmente independiente
quiero que te des cuenta que tanto sea 1
c 2 como c 4 tienen que ser 0 para que
se cumpla esta igualdad y la razón por
la que estoy construyendo todo esto es
que quiero que te des cuenta que si yo
pongo estas dos entradas cero entonces
este vector c1 c2 0 c 4 y 0 cumpla la
ecuación rx igual a 0 pero además yo sé
en que esta ecuación rx igual a 0 pero
además sabemos que las soluciones a esta
ecuación son exactamente las mismas que
las soluciones de la ecuación a x igual
a 0 y como sé eso a pues porque este es
el espacio nulo de la forma escalonada
de la matriz am es el conjunto solución
del espacio nulo de las formas
de la matriz a mientras que por esta
parte tengo el conjunto solución del
espacio el mundo de la matriz andy y
esto ya sabemos que es igual por lo
tanto las mismas soluciones tienen que
cumplir para estos dos y es que esto me
va a servir porque date cuenta que este
vector c1 c2 0 c 4 y 0 entonces también
debe ser solución de la forma a x igual
a 0 cuando sea 1 c 2 y c 4 son 0
entonces como sabemos que este vector
está en un espacio nulo de r
también está en espacios moldean y por
lo tanto se debe de cumplir que por este
vector tiene que ser igual al vector 0
justo por lo que tenemos aquí
y ojo recuerda que que me estoy tomando
dos entradas cero para que todo esto
tenga bastante sentido c3 y c5 tienen
que ser entradas que sean cero y ahora
esto me va a ayudar bastante a encontrar
la independencia lineal de mis vectores
columna de amp porque porque ahora sé
que ese uno por uno más c 2 x 2
se 4x4 porque esto me quedaría a cero
entonces me quedarían más de cuatro por
cuatro más cero por a cinco entonces no
lo voy a poner esto es igual a cero lo
único que estoy utilizando es que este
vector está en mi espacio nulo de ambas
matrices y bueno sabemos que en la
construcción debajo c1 c2 y c4 tenían
que ser cero por lo tanto aquí la única
solución y la única forma de que esto se
cumpla es que ese 1 c 2 y c 4 también
sean 0 porque tiene que ser exactamente
el mismo vector tomándonos estas dos
entradas como 0 recuerda que eso es muy
importante por construcción hicimos
estas dos entradas cero y bueno sí c1 c2
y c4 tienen que ser cero entonces me
está diciendo que estas tres son cero y
ya con esto estoy obteniendo que la
única solución a esta ecuación de azul
es que sea 1 c2 y c4 sean 0 y por lo
tanto esto quiere decir que el conjunto
de vectores a 1 a 2 y a 4 son
linealmente independientes es un
conjunto de vectores linealmente
independientes y perfecto justo a esto
quería llegar
y de encontrarme que este conjunto de
vectores eran linealmente independiente
y todo esto fue gracias a que nosotros
nos fijamos en la forma escalonada de la
matriz amp buscamos aquí las columnas
pivote y estas columnas pivote justo por
la manera en la que las construimos son
linealmente independientes y si son
linealmente independientes entonces
deben de cumplir la ecuación se uno por
r 1 más de 2 por r 2 c4 por r 4 igual a
cero y entonces yo puedo tomarme este
vector c1 c2 0 c 4 0 que por cierto está
en el espacio nulo tanto de la matriz
como de la matriz r y por lo tanto
cuando yo me tomo la multiplicación de
la matriz a por el vector segundo se
2004 y 0 entonces obtengo que los
vectores columnas asociados a las
columnas pivote de mi forma escalonada
de la matriz am son también linealmente
independientes y ahora para que tenga
una base en lo que nos falta es probar
que los dos vectores que no están
asociados a los vectores pivote los
podemos generar como una combinación
lineal de estos tres y esto es justo lo
que voy a ver en el siguiente vídeo